I bets you at 45 years old Trump
probably knew he's POS possibly going to
be running one day and he never really
told anybody outside of the people on
the inner circle Obama maybe at one
point knew hey you know one day I
wouldn't mind making a run out and see
what I can do a must one day probably
said I'm going to go out there and do
something and compete against NASA but
how do you say that to a friend and say
I'm going to beat NASA one day and you
don't know what everybody else is
thinking and what all their motives and
Visions are es M host Brian keing Kos
Amin be into the impossible p C welcome
Patrick it's good to be with you I
learned all my farsy just to say those
words to you that's all that's all I get
from you took me it took me a week to
memorize that that is impressive that is
impressive I thought maybe you were
maybe your your mom is Armenian farsy
and your dad is a Caucasian because
that's how my kids are my wife is white
from Texas yeah and the kid's father is
me so no I I get I get confused for that
I take it as a high compliment uh my my
Persian friends are are spectacular
anyway I got some help with that because
uh I've been wanting to meet you and do
this interview and talk about your
phenomenal new book but I got a question
for you Patrick so you're you're a
multi-millionaire you're one of the most
successful YouTubers in history uh you
left Iran with uh basically the shirt on
your back fled to Germany uh had this
exciting upbringing that you opened the
book up with you talk about it like it's
a James Bond opening scene in the James
Bond movie that's you why did you write
this book
and and let me ask you a question you
get fired today YouTube cancels you
something happens on iTunes it's not
uploading what are your next five moves
so that's a great question so let me
answer to both questions first of them
first of them first one is why did I
write this book so why I wrote this book
I wrote this book because years ago I
woke up in the morning and I never
forget this I felt lost I woke up in the
morning my phone had a text message from
my girlfriend saying you're spending way
too much time with the business I think
you love your business more than you
love me I think it's time we break up so
that's text 6 o'clock in the morning
message from a phone my mom's telling me
how bad of a son I am because I haven't
called her back and I don't hear from
you what happened to my little son that
wanted to talk to Mom so then I got the
guilt feeling so my heart's broken then
I have guilt then I check my email and
my email says that uh the client I had
just written up that was going to pay me
a good $155,000 commission he cancels
because he's going with the competitor
and then my number one sales rep also
resigned that all happens within a five
minute period in the morning when I woke
up when I woke up I said I have no idea
what to do next so in my mind at that
time we were having a lot of debates
with different friends where they were
talking about what s to success some
were saying the key to success is you
got to marry the right person you got to
go to school you gotta find God you got
to work hard you got to save money you
got to take care of your health all of
these different things so I said I
really want to know what is the key key
to success so when this has happened and
the dialogue about key to success and
this has happened in morning in the
first five minutes girlfriend break up
mom is disappointed you know clients
leaving me salesperson's leaving me I
realized years later the number one
reason why some people succeed is
because they have a system for how they
process issu so everything to me became
in that moment you could have 10
different people are going to react to
that problem in 10 different ways
someone's going to say oh let me call my
Mom first and then let me get together
with my girlfriend the whole day with
her and oh my gosh let me see so you the
sequence of how you handle that dictates
your success and fast forward to today
every single time we make decisions with
the company we wanted to come out with
systems because everything for us here
is about standard operating procedures
and it's about leaving clues that I can
teach you how to solve problems how to
solve issues how to negotiate so one of
the reasons why I wrote the your next
five moves is whether you're getting
married whether you want to have kids
whether you're thinking about going from
single to being committ to somebody
whether you want to be a millionaire
whether you want to lose 40 pounds
everything comes down to your next five
moves and most people don't do them
right they typically want to do move 13
on move number two it screws the whole
thing up so that's first question right
on on uh why I wrote the book the second
one is if I lost everything today what
would be my next five moves one of the
most comforting quotes I ever read was
there's two things they cannot take away
from you they can take everything away
from you they cannot take two things one
is what's in your stomach what you ate
it's there the second thing is what you
fed here so what you feed here and what
you feed here what you fed your stomach
it's done it's yours and what you feed
your mind so you can take everything
away from me I can be broke today i'
probably be depressed for a month and I
wouldn't want to see anybody and maybe
I'll spend some time with Jim Jack and
you know all those guys and you know
want to go out there and hang out with
friends to just want kind of want to get
over it and then eventually I'm gonna
snap at it and say Here's what I'm gonna
be doing and I'd be back at it again
with my next five moves so the
strategies that's what makes it more
Evergreen to any industry it's not
specific to an industry it's to any
industry when you uh hear the advice
that I'm about to give you uh I want to
see how you react to it so you often
hear um don't judge a book by its cover
but actually we all know people judge
books by their cover I'm curious how did
you come up with the idea for both the
cover the artwork on the cover and the
title itself the title and the subtitle
you and your co-author I should mention
that's a great question so number one
originally I wanted to name it software
X because in the book I talk about Sal
for X but s forx the you know we talk
about the fact that it is a good topic
but it's not a good title for a book
which I agreed then we agreed uh
originally when I was going to uh
publish it with penguin instead of Simon
and Shuster they like the deepest why
what is the deepest why because when
you're processing issues you have to get
to the deepest why so we said deepest
why then we said let's sof you went from
X to Y by the way you went from X to Y
so then my uh my uh uh agent said let's
go Sol for y s for y like wh Y which I
thought was pretty creative that was one
of the on that and then I said your next
15 moves they said 15 moves is way too
many l do your next five moves so you
pretty much got the whole you know what
took place with the processing of a
title and then the cover the way we
chose the cover is you know I like red
obviously vment is red and you know I I
like the color red that was chosen it's
a different kind of a red that's on
there and then I was originally going to
do it white with red on white I mean
white on red rather we said let's switch
it and let's make it to Red on white and
we switched it and the publisher
actually originally made the cover and
then eventually I just said let my
people make the cover and I had my
designer designed this cover so this
cover is actually not made by Simon and
schut this cover is made by us they
loved it and they said let's go with it
so we picked it wow that's fantastic
it's sometimes you know the last five
moves of a book as I know from uh just
the one one book that I've written uh
but nevertheless it's something that's
essential because people judge it they
judge you by your cover they judge the
the title and people judge you and judge
you know an individual based on as you
say what's in your head what's in your
character what's in your heart you focus
on that a lot in value tainment on
YouTube and we'll hopefully get to that
later on uh I want to come back to chess
I'm a scientist I'm a professor of
physics and astronomy at UC San Diego
where I run the Arthur C Clark Center
for human imagination and I'll be honest
we got a lot of nerds a lot of nerds
listen to this show watch this show on
YouTube and we love chess and I I you
know part of it when I started reading
it I was like hm is there going to be
like 200 openings you know from
capablanca to the king's Indian I was
kind of stoked about that to be honest
with you but as it got deeper I realized
this is another kind of genre and it's
not even limited to uh to the title you
know business strategy I think that
actually is a little limiting if I could
tweak it I would I would not limit it to
that because it's a psychology book it's
actually a selfimprovement book it's a
book that to me you know they talk about
comps what what is this book comparable
to to me it's kind of like this you know
strategic Art of War combined with Rich
Dad Poor Dad combined with you know Ray
Doo and and you know in reading it I was
like this kind of reminds me of that and
I looked at all the endorsements on the
back it's Ray Dolly o Kevin Hart uh
you've got uh you've got Robert kosaki
got all these big bigname people but
plus people like Steve wnc now most
people don't think of scientists like he
was or Engineers as outgoing you know
the old joke is how do you know an
engineer is outgoing he looks at your
shoes when he talks to you
but in this case you know I I was
thinking about it because I I used to
dabble in chess I'm not that great at
chess there actually is a book called
think like a Grandmaster and that's a
phrase you used in the book and you've
used in some videos it describes two
different personalities and I wonder
which do you cleave more to there's the
depth versus the breadth there's the guy
who can think or girl who can think 50
moves ahead not not five not 15 50 moves
ahead uh and and there may only be 20 or
30 reasonable moves that a human being
could do and then there's you know
that's the really deep one then there's
a broad one who studied all the openings
in that book that I thought you wrote
you know with all these opening moves
and everything and then then the kind of
the closing takes care of itself uh they
separate via intellectual horsepower the
the the CPU the computer cycles that are
devoted where do you see yourself are
you the Deep guy the broad guy the the
high horsepower intellect that just
drills down like a laser or are you
broad I I see behind you the shelf that
you talk about in the book uh you're
extremely well read uh I know that from
we have friends in common and they told
me that about you that you're just
thirsty so that to me speaks of breath
you don't just have one book that you've
read a 100 times you've got a thousand
bucks behind you and so what are you are
you a a deep guy are you a broad guy and
you can't say both let me tell you
that's a great question you ask so you
know we would do the analysis of the
four personality TS you know there's a
lot of different personality tests you
can take over the years you probably
taken all of them you know I'm an entj
I'm an you know all these guys put their
what they are the the one that we would
would talk about was star so star is
somebody who's very structured extremely
organized they're systematized
everything to them is system system
system then you have the technical which
very analytical they they like data they
break everything down they want to know
why this took place very very technical
then you have the a I'm GNA go take over
the world tell me I can't do it I'm G to
prove you wrong chippy competitive you
know chip on her shoulder then you have
the r tell me about yourself tell me
about your family tell me about your
life tell me who you are tell me how are
things you know very good with
compassion very good with building
relationship so for me for the longest
time I thought I was an artts I'm not an
S although if you ask anybody here I
hire s's all the time if you the the
best people that do very well with me
they're very organized because
everything in my life needs to be
organized even though I'm not organized
I have you know people that help me get
things organized eventually one day my
wife and I were sitting down and people
were asking and say so what is Pat you
know everybody I think Pat is an AR this
Pat is a this Pat is that she says I
don't know I think Pat's a te and they
said what do you mean and she says for
for five and a half years when I didn't
date him when I watched him from a
distance when we were in the same
company together Pat always had a very
strong personality so I thought for a
fact he was an A and he was always there
where if I needed help and relationship
and you know he was a good listener but
eventually I realized Pat a te Pats is
so analytical when it comes down to
everything what's the motiv behind this
why did they do this what was that
what's this all about and at this point
of the game I will tell you I'm probably
very I would I would give it a little
bit of an edge of a over T and then it's
RS s is the least but it's probably
going to be a and t very close to each
other when I was in college and I took
classes and I acce my classes I would
Ace calculus you know I would Ace
anything that had to do with math
outside of geometry I wasn't too
interested in Geometry I got to be in
Geometry but everything else that was a
lot of numbers a lot of dat of figuring
problems out that interested me and I
would fail biology I didn't have a lot
of interest in that so for you to ask
the depth versus the width uh extremely
curious my uncle was a physicist I was
always compared to my uncle that was
extremely analytical so I would say
there's an element of that I I'm always
curious to know if I was raised in a
family where my parents weren't in the
situation they were at and say they were
able to I was raised with a father and a
mother and I went to college I was
always curious know what I would do I
don't know what I would do would I go
get a degree in law or physicist or
physics or any of that stuff but uh it's
a great question you're asking I'd say
some technical and action combined my
thumbs rather occupied right now holding
up good old Carl Sean but yours is free
to push that like button and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode that brings up you we talk about
personality tests and and everything and
I I can never remember if I'm a right
brain or a left brain and I think that
means I'm one of those two brains I got
to be one of them right uh but but
nevertheless I'm a behaviorist I like to
look at how people behave and sometimes
the the owner's manual you know when my
my wife and I had our first kid one day
he was crying and I'm just like uh get
the owner's manual it's like there is no
owner's manual you know you've got kids
and uh but I think you know there are
tools in this book both in the book in
the actual appendix of the book and uh
and elsewhere online at your next5
moves.com which we'll put links to in
the show notes uh that are really about
you know practical tips to actually do
stuff and as I was thinking about this
book there another book that kind of
reminded I thought it would remind me of
it because I'm also a private pilot in
my spare time which is not that much and
we always have checklists we always have
flight plans and a flight plan is just
your next five moves I mean you can't
actually know where this cloud is going
to be or you're going to run out of uh
you know fuel over there some passenger
gonna have to take go to the bathroom
you could only plan a few moves at ahead
and you gotta be flexible and one of the
things I liked about this book compared
to say at G's um the checklist Manifesto
which has some similarities is that
there's actual actionable way that you
can approach it so I I really salute
that uh process and you have this you
know personality audit and we've gone
over it and but to impact 200 100,000
people I was kind of doing a little
simple math how many other you know
tools have had such impact I mean and
actually you wrote this in and you know
you published this you started writing
it probably finished it last year early
this year it's probably even more so how
do you feel about that impact that
you're making for people like me who are
kind of geeky nerds to actually sit down
be introspective about what they're
doing is is that a value to you what is
a value to me is when I run into
somebody at the airport or the mall or
somewhere I'm out there and I'm at
school and one of the kids parents is a
vainer and they come up and they say you
know the other day I was coming home at
10 o'clock at night a guy was chasing me
I'm like wait a minute what is this guy
chasing me I'm pretty protective my kids
and my wife's I come out I go up to the
guy says no no no no no I'm just I'm
just somebody my wife and I watch all
your content Indian engineer that works
at a local place and he's 10 years older
I me we had a great conversation
together what what is reward is to hear
people that the philosophies and the
content shared on value tment helped
them get clear on a decision they had to
make it's very very rewarding what I
what I don't do to myself is I don't sit
there and make myself think that it's
that big of a deal of what I'm doing
because it goes back to the sto stoic of
Marcus aelius who would put a slave
behind him whispering in his ear you are
not as important as you think you are
because sometimes I think when we
uh allow too much of the edification and
the praise and the flattery that comes
your way you are almost stunt you know
it it stunts your growth to the next
level and I'm always I'm curious about
the unknown you know because I already
know what today feels like I want to
know what this feels like what is what
is the possibility of raising kids who
one day they're able to do stuff their
dad couldn't do and you know they're
inspired to take this mindset to the
next level I'm always curious about the
so in one way very rewarding uhuh on the
other other side I also don't put a lot
of a uh I don't wake up and say oh my
gosh I need more of it yeah hopefully
we'll get a chance to talk to what is
your next level both in terms of you
personally as Patrick but also her
competition because you're in a very
heated field you're in a very
competitive um Market unlike you know me
there's there's more you know people
playing starting lineup in the NBA than
practicing experimental cosmologists who
are studying the origin of the universe
uh so but that can be also challenging
because if you're in a a smaller Pond
you know sometimes it's the the the
competition could be pretty darn Fierce
as well especially in Academia nowadays
but I want to talk to you about possible
competitors and some of the stuff that I
see you know I'm sure he's not watching
this but you know it's people like Gary
ve and other it's like there's so much
of these types of people ritti and other
people like really promoting this idea
of hustle and and finding your your
Niche and just uh they'll teach you to
be rich rich dad even Rich Dad Poor Dad
you know some think it's a little bit on
this on the on the scammy side just to
be honest with you and sometimes they're
all in Conflict like there's there's a
lot of psychology in this book and what
I like about it is you're just like
here's what you do when somebody ticks
you off take responsibility State
specifically what you did Channel your
frustration into getting better so it's
a self-improvement book masquerading as
a business book but what do you say to
people um like some of the Skeptics who
who like feel about Gary ve or or
somebody like that that they are really
just kind of promoting their own book
they're really like to use the insurance
from or whatever like they're selling
their own stuff and and they actually
are depending on people to fail it seems
like you are engaged with people
succeeding not failing like Weight
Watchers they only make business because
people like me go back and recidivism is
high how do you how do you like uh keep
Integrity in such in such an environment
you know I read a quote a long time ago
by is is is it Richard Branson the guy
from Virgin I think it's Richard Branson
he said teach your guys your employees
everything that you know so they can go
away leave you and compete against you
but treat them so well that they don't
want to okay that's a fascinating
message to be given right where it's I'm
G to share everything I do with you guys
I said like one of the things I have a
reputation for if you work with me I
always like to do meetings and another
person sit next to me because I want you
to learn how I negotiate I want you to
learn how I put out a fire I want you to
know and see well that one time pat got
heated but he went from heated to this
point and how was he able to bring it
down and why did he get heated and but
he's done the seven different times and
it's always worked out well and what
happened there how is it that two
personalities get heated and then they
end up becoming friends and do business
together for a long time and you know he
realizes what area he has to say that
was my bad we'll fix it and the other
area puts the pressure on the other
person because because it's an element
of shadowing and learning from somebody
else on what to do and what not to do
right that that's that's a part of uh
doing that but but going back to these
guys and what they're doing look my my
idea is I was one time interviewed with
I think car
and Cardone one time said you know I was
telling him the fact that communism is
not a good idea he says well communism
is good if you're the Communist in
charge and I said I have no desire for
power because power comes easy I don't
care about that I'm driven by a freedom
I left Iran to come here because I
wanted Freedom so as far as some of
these other guys what they're doing um I
think time will tell us too early to
tell who's who and what they're doing
you got 10 more years 20 more years to
really tell what people's outcomes were
some people's outcomes you're not going
to know some of them you're just not
going to get revealed for a very long
time like I bet you at 45 years old
Trump probably knew he's possibly going
to be running one day and he never
really told anybody outside of the
people on the inner circle and he
thought about it what if I run one day I
promise you that uh and Obama maybe at
one point knew hey you know one day I
wouldn't mind making a run out and see
what I can do you know a musk one day
probably said I'm gonna go out there and
do something and compete against NASA
but how do you say that to a friend and
say I'm going to beat NASA one one day
and NASA's going to say you know for us
to go to space stay there for two weeks
and come back and have safe landing is
going to take 12 years and 26 billion
dollar this is a committee led by Obama
Le committee that said it's going to
take 12 years 26 billion and here's a
Elon Musk that's an entrepreneur comes
and says I'm going to do it in six years
with less than a billion dollars I mean
you have to know you don't know what
everybody else is thinking and what all
their motives and Visions are but when
you listen to everybody today with what
they're messaging is some people are
just driven by money and Fame and
success you know some people are simply
looking for that and there's nothing
wrong with that some people just want
more and more and more of success and
credit and all that other stuff and some
are not some's vision is much bigger
than that and unfortunately I said this
to a couple of my friends the other day
we're sitting now I do I run a mentoring
call on Tuesdays with the executives of
my company I said how do you know who's
a Visionary so I said I got a question
for all of you can you tell me the
difference between a Visionary and a
bullshitter what is the difference
because they both talk a big game
they're both sales right they're both
salesmen my wife told me she says you
know you and my ex have one thing in
common and one thing that was very
different I said what is it she said you
know both of you were very good at
talking dirty about what you're G to do
big in your life one day I said what's
the difference you actually did it so so
you don't know the difference between
somebody that's like one day we're going
to go out there one day we're going to
go out there you don't know if this
guy's telling the truth or not the only
way going to know it's going to take a
decade or two so I think it's still very
early in the game I I think we'll have
to revisit this when we're in our
mid-50s or early 60s to see what
everybody's really up to and at that
point of the game it's going to get very
clear and by the way here's one thing we
have to realize that too often we forget
that there's been many people who were
celebrities at one point that were
forgotten about we're very quick to
forget that I mean oh yeah just because
somebody's a start today we think this
person is going to be around forever
it's very very hard the reason why Ray
Charles and sting have so much respect
is because they had a number one hit in
four different decades it is very very
difficult to stay relevant for a long
time so I think it's too early but we'll
find out what happens in the next few
decades so I want to ask you because
it's not so often I get to speak with
someone so knowledgeable about insurance
and I I want you to convince me that I'm
wrong I think insurance is a scam
basically people are betting in the
insurance company that I'm gonna live
and I'm betting I'm G to die uh or vice
versa and I'm just like I look at it
like a Cas you were just out in Vegas I
understand from the podcast it was kind
of dead out there but you look at these
casinos and they have no windows in them
and they're palaces and it's like the
maximum Edge you can possibly get in any
game besides poker is like 1.5% that the
house has 1.5% Edge and with that edge
they can make millions and millions
billions of dollars and some at least
before now how is Insurance different
from that I mean they got to be making
you know making making serious money
somehow and if that's by betting that
you're going to you know that you're
you're betting you're going to die and
so you want to protect protect against
that are most insurance policies
basically scams or am I just totally
full of it so I'm going to ask the
question different for from you let me
ask you when does the insurance company
make more money if you keep the policy
or cancel the policy oh you want to they
want you to keep it right no the other
way around oh they have terminations and
stuff like I have insurance from the
governor that you love so much gav Gavin
Newsome so I love so much yeah you're
right but you know I will tell you this
think about it yeah the insurance the
only way you get even with a life
insurance company is if you keep your
policy if you keep your policy you win
they lose give you a perfect example so
think about it the insurance policy is
hoping every time there's a crisis like
this that like right now coronavirus
took place right guess who made money
all the insurance companies made money
why let me explain to you why life
insurance companies made money what do
you think is one of the first things
people cancel when a crisis takes place
cancel their insurance they they cancel
the life insurance policy now watch this
I say I've had a term insurance policy
with medlife and I've had it for 12
years and I've been paying $80 a month
it's a million dollar policy okay crisis
takes place I cancel my insurance policy
I was paying $80 a month right $80 a
month over 12 years is how much money
it's around $112,000 yeah but that
$112,000 now kept by who the insurance
company if I now wanted to start an
insurance policy would it be $80 a month
no it'd be higher because I'm 12 years
older and I'm probably heavier I
probably had a couple surgeries so my
$80 a month for million is now $400 a
month so if you wanted to buy a policy
now you're paying five times more than
you were paying before so insurance
companies make money because they know
most people don't keep their insurance
policies and once you cancel your
insurance policy and it lapses that's
all profits going to the insurance
company so the best way to get even with
life insurance companies is buy it and
don't cancel they hate that if you buy
it and don't ever cancel it they
eventually have to pay out the ma to you
the money to you and what about you know
some bu bypassing you know what you what
you guys do and go directly like can I
get a better policy if I just a better
deal me as Brian keading I go to the
insurance why do I need Patrick why do I
need the company the way math works on
life insurance is there is not a
wholesale retail meaning if you buy it
from me or you buy it directly from AIG
or you buy it from another agent that
works for me it's the same exact rate
there is no you know if I buy this uh uh
from directly wholesale it's going to
cost you $4 but if you buy it from
Amazon is $14 but if you buy it from me
at a swap meet is $22 that's not how
Insurance works whatever the insurance
you can go to a website called term for
sale and it just tells you everybody's
price for their life insurance policy so
you don't even need to have an agent you
just go find out what is the cheapest
term insurance policy for your age and
how much you want and that's the price
no matter who you buy it from direct
from a website from an individual so
there is no wholesale retail when it
comes on to life insurance pricing okay
uh the next next topic I want to turn to
uh really comes through uh in your in
the acknowledgement section at the end
of the book uh which is easily devoured
and um you obviously thank your wife
your co-author Etc uh but the the most
kind of touching thing to me was this
following sentence um how value tainers
uh have impacted you so I wouldn't be
writing this book you say or creating
new content if it weren't for the
millions of value tainers and
entrepreneurs who follow the content on
a monthly basis I'm grateful to you you
energize me in ways that words can't
describe first of all was your wife
pissed off that you acknowledge the
value tainers almost as much as you did
to
her my wife probably the most easy going
person you'll meet in your life so I go
to the value tainment uh YouTube channel
I click on about and it says an
entrepreneur Channel created by serial
entrepreneur Patrick Bet davit value
tainment is referred to as the best
channel for entrepreneurs with weekly
how-tos motivation interviews with
Unique Individuals you've done such an
amazing job with the channel it gave me
an idea you reputedly I talked to one of
your high school guidance counselors uh
you had a 1.8 GPA you didn't go to
college you went to the Army thank you
so much for doing that US Army and
you've become this huge success um my
question for you is if you if you were
not going to go to college but you're
going to create bet David University
what would you offer what would you
teach the students there that they would
need to know and could uniquely learn
from you let me tell you it would be all
human nature it would be all debate my
entire educ so you got to realize I go
on four different 20- year terms right
first 20 years was don't make a big
mistake second 20 years is go find one
industry stick to it and make your money
like real money so you can take that
money in the next one combine your your
Crusade your cause your passion and turn
it into a business which is the next 20
years and the last 20 years is a form of
contribution given back politics
education nonprofit etc etc if I were to
start a university one day let's call it
B David University my University would
be very very different here's how my
University would be if we're teaching if
we're teaching economics you would have
have two professors or maybe three
professors you would have a socialist a
communist and a capitalist and you get
to watch them debate non-stop that's how
I would teach if you want to have you
know a course you're taking on marriage
and relationship you would have somebody
that's single never got married you'd
have somebody that's divorced happily
divorced and you got somebody that's
happily married they're each going to
sell you why you ought to consider
getting married why you ought to
consider you know marriage is tough to
be or I'm just happy staying single if
I'm teaching you negotiation skills you
would get the people that are you know
hostage negotiators you would get people
that went to prison and are drug dealers
you'd get the people that worked in the
streets you get the people that worked
in the business world that did the
biggest deals when it comes out to
negotiation you will learn that you'd
learn human nature you would have people
sitting down on stage and I would say
can you read that person's body language
how do they feel right now do they trust
you do they not trust you what's that
giving you what is this giving you how
do you read this person's tail how do
you read that person's tale it would be
a very different kind of a human nature
University to'd be going to and then of
course we would have the courses to
teach but it wouldn't be about oh I got
a four-year degree from bed David
University right it would be it would be
more closer to an academy a a military
toughness mental emotional toughness
type of an academy when you come out of
there being the future Governor
president cosos you know disruptors of
the world that would be more the mindset
than more let me go take a you know
philosoph do you feel like augmented
reality and artificial intelligence has
a role to actually play in that where
you could war game with genas Khan could
put you know Robert E Lee over there you
could do sort of the battles and the
skirmishes and and car KL marks you know
and and and you know Adam Smith put them
together could could you see that have
you spoken to anybody that knows me very
well that I wrote a fiction book do you
know what's in the fiction book or no I
don't I'm sorry no I didn't do my
homework don't get me an please no one
knows that I thought maybe you have gone
that far because so I have a fiction
book that I wrote It's 95,000 WS that I
will not launch until I leave PHP
because it it kind of reveals how I view
the world and what I would be doing it's
it's it's a little bit political it's a
little bit controversial people are
gonna say this guy's a little weird on
how we've used things but one of the
things is studying uh uh you know I have
a painting on the wall right there that
I show me characters it's called Dead
mentors so you'll see Lincoln there
you'll see JFK it's opposing
personalities by the way Einstein who's
a math genius but he believed in
socialism Milton Freedman who's a math
genius but he's a capitalist MLK who
took his approach in a different way and
Tupac who took a approach little more
controversial and then I have Senna
who's Fierce competitive then you have
the Sha in the middle and they're
debating two books Communist Manifesto
and Atlas Shrug in the middle and then
you got Marcus aelius and you got
Aristotle and a bunch of hidden stuff
and it's a vault they're in a bank vault
having strong debates together so for me
why waste all these dead people that did
incredible things in their lives
mistakes good things bad things why not
study them the univers what I talk about
in the fiction book it's kind of a
combination of Hunger Games Divergent
meets I am a legend All combined
together that's kind of what that book
is about but two three years from now to
be out but some of the stuff you talked
about is actually in that book I wrote
it like seven years ago oh I'd love to
I'd love to read that help out whatever
way I can that's uh really fascinating I
feel like you know I'm a pretty smart
guy I'm a good professor but you know am
I better than Galileo you know you want
to sit down with with Galileo to learn
about that uh to learn about you know
motion or Einstein learn about
relativity obviously you do then so um
you know we can Aspire and I think
having that you mentioned that painting
in the book it's great to see it in in
person so to speak I want to move now to
a couple uh you know sort of Rapid Fire
questions and then I want to uh conclude
with some questions I ask all my guests
if you if you still have a little bit of
time um first question is given all the
personalities you've interacted with I
see you as this kind of like molecule
that's literally been on you know all
these different continents except
Antarctica that might be the only place
I've been that you haven't been but
never I don't know maybe you've been
there uh we could do a value attainment
uh Summit there but um I want to ask you
of all the personality types you meet
which is kind of the worst thing you
look for and avoiding a person uh and
what are kind of the best things that
you look for in in working with someone
an employee uh obviously integrity and
it's different in a spouse but let me
just say in an employee employer Dynamic
what are some of the things you you
avoid like the plague uh sorry to bring
that up or and things that you gravitate
towards like a magnetic field so it
depends on what the position is and what
you're doing for example I'll break it
down for if I'm dealing with a sales
person uh or somebody is in sales that's
working
1099 I look for somebody that played
Sports I look for somebody that's got a
chip I look for somebody that uh you
know had a massive public humiliation of
a loss a breakup I look for somebody
that had major challenges that took
place with them uh I look for that if
I'm dealing with uh uh sales and S
because they have to be competitive you
got to be willing to do the work work 60
80 hours a week if I'm dealing with
somebody that's more operations and
customer service I'm looking for
somebody that's you know maybe a certain
spiritual Foundation Faith but where a
little bit more easygoing to deal with
customers and you know like one of the
folks I have work in here Alexa she's
I've never met anybody that's that good
with people I've never met anybody
that's that good with people and she
she's able to address issues in a way
that others can she came from sales but
she wasn't good in sales but is very
good in dealing with people so the same
person didn't do well in sales but she
does very well when it comes on to uh
addressing issues then if I'm dealing
with somebody that's uh finances and
it's economics I almost need somebody
that's a little bit of a loner uh uh you
know I need somebody that's not doesn't
talk too much that uh maybe is not very
personable maybe is a little bit private
uh doesn't uh won a lot of bragging
rights you know he just kind of wants to
do the job and you know uh uh get
respected forward once there's an exit
or a victory that's what I look for when
it come when it comes down to somebody
with money Finance when I'm dealing with
operations I'm dealing with
somebody who is extremely analytical yet
stepbystep process and little bit
annoying little bit quirky little bit
like can get under your skin a little
bit you know like you're you're semi
annoying obnoxious but you trust it
because they just have a method of you
know back to back to back to back to
back they can do the same thing over and
over again so again going back to
answering your question for it all
depends on position and department but
yes everybody has a little bit of a
quirk that helps in that department
great I want to turn towards I'll I'll
I'll have a one more rapid fire question
but before I get there I want to talk
about the YouTube channel uh because I
have about the square root of the number
of subscribers that you do uh which is
not that many you know from mathematics
uh but uh nevertheless I want to ask you
how did you build it uh what was kind of
the inspiration for doing and and
obviously I'd like to know how how can
somebody like me starting off develop it
grow an audience um uh you know think
about how do you think about
monetization Etc I I don't really focus
so much on that but growing the YouTube
channel what it's done for you what it's
done against you you know because it's
made you the superstar in a certain
sense and I want to talk about Fame and
and at the very end of this but first of
all how did you do it what's um what
what are some tips or five moves that we
can apply out there and U that are
aspiring first of all let me ask you
this how many people have you
interviewed yourself how many people
have you interview 68 68 okay I've been
interviewed by a lot of people your top
three best ever that's ever interviewed
I'm not you can't you can't see me say
this to other people so if you go watch
other people that have interviewed me
I've never said this to anybody so I'm
saying this to you because you're you're
gentle you make me trust you to open up
to you and talk to and it's almost like
it's just you and I even though there's
audience that's watching us the idea of
somebody that can interview has to make
me feel uh very comfortable that I'm
speaking to them you can do that you are
able to to proper research you're asking
questions other people are not asking so
you're not the
conventional yeah I mean Merc Mercy
Mercy yes you are welcome